اذا العديد من التصريحات تشير الى ان
اسرائيل لم تحقق اهدافها كيف تقيم او كيف
تصف التكتيكات الاسرائيليه بعد اكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر ولم تحقق فيها اسرائيل تلك
الاهداف يعني اولا لا يوجد تكتيكات في
الماضي حتى يكون تكتيكات جديده حقيقه هو
كل ما جرى حتى الان قصف بالطيران قصف
تدميري سياسه ارض محروقه حرب اباده جماعيه
تطهير عرقي قصف مدفعيه بريه وقصف مدفعيه
بحريه اي تقدم
بالدبابات احتماء الجنود الاسرائيليين
بهذه
الدبابات تتقدمها الجرافات تجرف البنيه
التحتيه تدمر المنازل تسويها بالارض
والجنود الاسرائيليين لا يوجد لديهم خطه
عسكريه وهذا باعترافهم هم طبعا ولا يوجد
لديهم اهداف سوى الهدفين الاساسيين الذي
الذان حددا لهما في البدايه
وهما القضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وت
تحرير الاسرى بالقوه العسكريه حتى الان لم
يق لم يتم تنفيذ هذين الهدفين اضافه الى
انهم لا يعلمون شيء الان عن قدرات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولا عن الانفاق ولا
عن الاسر ولا ولا يوجد لديهم يعني خطط
بمعنى الخطط وهناك شكوى من الضباط والجنود
الاسرائيليين بانهم اي لديهم نقص في
الاسلحه وفي الذخائر وفي المعلومات
الامنيه والاستخباري وبان الخطط التي تم
زجهم من اجل
تنفيذها يعني فيها رتابه وفيها عدم قدره
على تحقيق الاهداف وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل
على تدني الروح المعنويه عند الجنود
الاسرائيليين وتراجع بالكفاءه القتاليه
وفي هذه الحاله لا جدوى من بقائهم في مسرح
العمليات وكذلك في المقلب الاخر ب بعد
اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر المقاومه في غزه لا
تزال تحقق اهدافا لا تزال تحقق يوميا
انجازات عسكريه عديده كيف تفسر ذلك وكيف
تفسر هذا
الصمود يعني اولا هذا الصمود نتيجه اولا
ايمان وعقيده عند المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
ومعرفتهم لطبيعه عدوهم يعني ما ما يميز
المقاوم الفلسطيني عن الجندي الاسرائيلي
ان المقاوم الفلسطيني يعرف كل شيء عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي ويشاهده وينظر ويتابعه
وينصب له الكمائن ويشتبك معه من مسافه صفر
الجندي الاسرائيلي لا يوجد لديه معلومات
عن المقاومين الفلسطينيين لانه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لا ليس جيشا و ولا يوجد له
مواقع ثابته او دفاعيه ولا يتحصن بدبابه
او باليه هو يخرج له من تحت تحت الركام
ومن تحت المنازل المدمره ومن الانفاق
فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن امكانيات هائله عند
الجيش الاسرائيلي دبابات طائرات مدفعيه
اليات مجنزره اسلحه حديثه ولكن لا يوجد من
من يستخدمها بمعنى ان السلاح لوحده لا
يقاتل من يحمل السلاح هو الذي يقاتل
ويقاتل بمعنويات هي
وبكفائة الفلسطيني يقاتل يقاتل بسلاحه
بالشاشه بكوع الفدائي المتفجر بلغم شواب
وبقد في الار بيجي فبالتالي هذه المعركه
مهما طال امدها ستبقى لصالح المقاومين
الفلسطينيين والجيش الاسرائيلي لا يمكن له
ان يحقق انجازات او اهداف على الارض بما
انه يتصرف بهذه الطريقه شكرا لك من رام
الله لواء الركن المتقاعد وصف عريقات
الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه